🎤🎧♫ Mélodie d'introduction 🎤🎧♫
Non j'suis pas un vendu
Mais j'ai des choses à vendre
Cordon bleu Père Dodu
Possède un goût de légende
Trottinette Décathlon
À gogo sur le guidon
Je dérape sur ce son
Cacolac comme boisson
Viens donc acheter tous mes produits secrets
Les commander, tester, tu vas les adopter
Calés au Formule 1 sereins sur un bon lit douillet
Formule à 10 euros bébé je t'emmènerai fluncher
Puis on se brossera les dents avec la nouvelle Oral-B
C'est facile tu appuies juste ici puis ça s'met à tourner (hey)
Tu fais la pitre, t'es pas très nette
j'te Apta Vitres ton Art Et Fenêtres
Un bobo ?
Hansaplast
Un virus ?
Go Avast
Ding Dong ?
Wellington
Oh c'est beau ?
Ocedar
Lucas dis leur qu'mes articles y sont bons
Et on brade pour du clic on fait d'la promotion
J'bois du Freeway Cola sur ce son qui t'séduis
Gros big up à tonton qui tient Pizza Tony
J'fais des placements d'produits parce que j'ai besoin d'Youtube Money
J'fais des placements d'produits mais ça déçoit mes abonnés
J'fais des placements d'produits même si parfois j'ai des remords
J'fais des placements d'produits ouais dès demain je roule sur l'or
J'fais des placements de produits parce que j'ai besoin d'Youtube Money
J'fais des placements d'produits mais ça déçoit mes abonnés
J'fais des placements d'produits même si parfois j'ai des remords
J'fais des placements de produits ouais dès demain je roule sur l'or
Posé sur Habbo Hotel
Avec ma gow au tél
Plus d'réseau j'ai les pétoches
J'vais p't'être cette fois passer chez Sosh
J'prépare ma purée Vico
J'tente de rallumer l'tél Wiiko
Échec j'vais voir les potos
J'suis cool j'ramène les Ficello
Meuf avec moi no douilles
J'te met bien comme le gratte-dos de la Foir'Fouille
J'sais qu'tu m'regardes de loin ce soir viens au festin n'aie pas la trouille
Cassoulet Cassegrain
Pourquoi pas Willam Saurin
Boisson Marque Repère
Maïs Géant Vert
J't'emmène au resto au Buffalo ou à l'Hippo
Grillades ou salades j't'invite c'est pas du pipeau
Merde la sauce sur l'pantalon elle va griller
(elle va griller)
J'ai mon Vanish Oxi Action pour nettoyer
(pour nettoyer)
J't'emmène à la piscine même si j'sais pas nager
J'suis un gangster
J'regarderai tes formes en buvant du Panaché
Et un pervers
J'fais des placements d'produits parce que j'ai besoin d'YouTube Money
J'fais des placements d'produits mais ça déçoit mes abonnés
J'fais des placements d'produits même si parfois j'ai des remords
J'fais des placements d'produits ouais dès demain je roule sur l'or
J'fais des placements d'produits parce que j'ai besoin d'Youtube Money
J'fais des placements d'produits mais ça déçoit mes abonnés
J'fais des placements d'produits même si parfois j'ai des remords.
J'fais des placements d'produits ouais dès demain je roule sur l'or
♫ Musique ♫
[Lucas] Maxenss, j'crois qu'on a un problème...
[Maxenss] Bah qu'est-ce qu'il y a Lucas ?
[Lucas] Bah, on fait de moins en moins de vues et les gens se désabonnent...
[Maxenss] Oh non c'est pas vrai...
Tu crois qu'on a fait une connerie ?
J'fais plus d'placements d'produits pour retrouver ma dignité
J'fais plus d'placements d'produits car j'ai perdu mes abonnés
J'fais plus d'placements d'produits et c'est trop tard pour les remords
J'fais plus d'placements d'produits même si maintenant je roule sur l'or
J'fais plus d'placements d'produits pour retrouver ma dignité
J'fais plus d'placements d'produits car j'ai perdu mes abonnés
J'fais plus d'placements d'produits et c'est trop tard pour les remords
J'fais plus d'placements d'produits même si maintenant je roule sur l'or
🎧♫ Petite mélodie finale (courte) ♫🎧